[Music]
oh yeah this recap totally reminds me
about that episode in which bando and
breaking bad did the thing with the
stuff and alerted the people that the
whatchamacallit was happening and so the
dude went to the place for that period
of time
all caught up 27 seconds of logos for a
tv
show also i just realized they've been
spelling star trek wrong this whole time
dino cranes i'm sure he's doing some
daily labor but this doesn't look half
bad for a prison
you get out into the open air work on a
project and they even give you proper
ppe
hell they could have frozen him in
carbonite so if i were migs i'd be
counting my blessings inmate three four
six six seven
please follow martial duke to transport
somebody gonna tell me what's going on
here well that was easy is this
seriously all it takes to spring a
prisoner
seemed like vanda was setting us up for
a [ __ ] heist when he asked cara this
last episode
and he didn't even know she was a
marshal before he got there so what was
he gonna do if she didn't have any
official republic authority
also i get that mayfield is a cautious
guy but he's also been in prison with
i'm assuming only men
and someone who looks like gina carano
just showed up wanting him to follow her
does star wars not understand how boners
work make three four six six seven i
swear to god they refer to migs by his
inmate number so many times in the
beginning of this episode it's like
they're trying to force me to memorize a
phone number and no one remembers phone
numbers anymore
oh cool but we got a glow up but
seriously there were
deep scratches on that armor including
whatever chemical reaction happened
while being partially digested by the
sarlacc
so how do you get this so clean in the
short amount of time he's had it
also how do you replace the rocket on
his back he used that sucker to blow up
the stormtroopers in the last episode so
it should be disintegrated
hell marshall cobb also used it in his
episode
how does this thing keep getting
restored that was a long time ago all
right
but you still know your imperial
clearances and protocols but would they
still be active after being away for a
long
time seriously i was once fired from a
fast food place and couldn't get out the
door because they'd already deleted my
security code in the 30 seconds it took
me to get my
together man this show sure does love it
some ascending ship porn
whoa how things get changed so quickly
and where do they have his clothes
stored did they stop by a goth version
of j
crew on the way over here to pick up
some duds they have his kid
the little green guy and mayfield would
care about this why when he first ran
into mando and grogu he said this
me i was never really into pets yeah i
didn't have the temperament
and after that mando got him arrested
and imprisoned in the scrapyard they
just pulled him from why would he want
to help mando at all
all right but here's the thing i can't
get those coordinates unless i have
access to an internal imperial terminal
look i know he's trying to dial the
accent back a bit but bilper is a
masshole and it's really odd that
there's an obvious masshole a long time
ago in a galaxy far far away
there's nothing on morak at this point
in the series hasn't mando been proven
wrong about existing places that aren't
supposed to be there enough times that
he wouldn't even bother with his
argument anymore
punch in the coordinates fat fat
who the hell calls him fat is his whole
name too hard to say
are they not on a first name basis after
he pledged his fealty to mando for this
quest
remember how pissed han was when finn
called him solo in the force awakens
i wonder what they were finding in there
looks like rydonia
you can tell that from a blurry hologram
why does any vehicle in this universe
have wheels it's clear that hover
technology exists and works on even the
poorest planets like
tatooine or jakku wheels would make
everything more treacherous
especially if you're transporting a
highly volatile resource imagine what
the crew and sorcerer would have done if
they'd had access to hover technology
you think they'd be
with that rotten bridge it's gonna be me
going in alone
or say goodbye to your little green
friend wait how does he know what i call
my vibrator
also maf gideon's had grogu for at least
a few days now
even if it takes a while to get where
he's going they must have extracted
enough blood or stool or whatever the
hell they need from him along the way to
do their evil
i'm just saying mando should have been
moving much faster from the jump if he
thinks he's actually going to rescue the
kid
i'm not saying cara couldn't handle her
own against these two guys but armando
and mayfield not going to jump down and
at least
see if she needs any assistance also
more helmet punching
i don't care if these aren't best car
they should be at least somewhat
protective right otherwise why the heck
are they wearing them
just make sure you take out the rooftop
gunners hey why does bando sound the
exact same in this helmet as his regular
one
are the voice modulators the same seems
like there'd be at least a slight tonal
disparity
show decides we need to know the steps
mayfield takes to understand the
mechanics of this vehicle and i
assure you we do not i'm taking this
thing off
i can't see anything first off if mix
can't see anything how does
anyone see anything out of one of those
helmets also mix leaves this
off for the rest of the episode and even
though he's ex-imperial and stuff
troopers
are supposed to wear their helmets right
show could not make it more obvious that
they need to easily identify these two
that are dressed in identical uniforms
i don't know how you people wear those
things that's racist and by you people i
do mean mandalorians
still racist don't worry about the
rhidonium
as long as you drive steady you'll get
us to the refinery
wages of mandalorians also how the heck
does mando know that
also also when did star wars become
obsessed with fuel sources
last jedi solo a star wars story now
this unobtainium crap why do we care
about the fuel oh yeah that's
definitely necessary there's no way
these [ __ ] can see this giant
transport coming their way
also hey those are villagers on this
planet human even
yet mando confidently explained there
was nothing on this planet a few minutes
ago despite it being habitable and
honestly
quite pleasant i'm a survivor just like
you another we're not so different you
and me cliche
didn't we just get this in the michael
bean standoff a few episodes ago
the hell's that if that monitor was
right in mando's line of sight this
whole time how did he not see the
pirates until they already jumped on the
ship
furthermore if they heard the single
pirate jump on this clearly how did the
real stormtroopers not hear
three of these idiots jump on the roof
just a few moments ago
are you seriously shooting a blaster
near rydonia mayfield would be excellent
at tv sense
you know these are supposed to be
pirates which means they're looking for
booty right
so why are they just straight destroying
the juggernauts instead of taking the
ridonium or whatever else is valuable
cargo what do they get out of just
blowing this stuff up
pick it up drive faster and i'm sure
migs can hear this while driving rapidly
down a dirt road while inside the cab in
the middle of a pirate attack
oh you say that there are comms in the
helmets of these trooper uniforms
well migz isn't wearing his so there
this is the third round of not pirates
that amanda will have to fend off
we know mano isn't going to blow up or
die here which is to say this battle
goes on for
all the some time
yeah totally time to celebrate since
these tie fighters are nowhere close to
hitting the pirates on the initial view
blast mix was worried about mando's
blaster fire a few seconds ago but he's
all wine and roses when the freaking
heavy artillery is opening fire at the
transport carrying very unstable cargo
yeah don't pay any attention to the
thermal detonator that was thrown just
keep moving towards it and firing away
[ __ ] stormtroopers i can't do it okay
we gotta feel bored i'm sorry
niggs is all worried about being
recognized by this butthole but what's
the big deal
even if he did recognize him as a field
operative in a previous campaign
it was for the empire right so he'd
either get glad-handed or receive a nod
of welcome at the most
also he went in there showed his face
and is now acting super cagey
if dude didn't recognize him before he'd
be much more suspicious now
helmet hair
facial scan complete what
why would mando's facial scan grant him
access to classified imperial
data also if this was going to be the
case then why did they need mayfeld in
the first place they could have just
questioned him about what to do back at
the scrap yard and been on their way
also also the heck is up with that
mustache why even bother with a mustache
if you're going to wear the helmet all
the live long day
you're telling me he manscapes this
diligently but refuses to show that
magnificent lip rug
you're the tank troopers have delivered
the shipment of radonium
how does this dude know that the
shipment was delivered he's been sitting
here with his buddy drinking in the mess
hall and they just got here before
walking straight into the room
how about a toast to operation cinder
mix was scared to death just a few
seconds ago about this dude recognizing
him but now that he knows he's not going
to be recognized his balls drop and he
decides to provoke this dill hole
instead of having his drink and getting
the crap
out of there once who died was it good
for them i have to say this scene really
makes as much sense as star-lord
punching thanos in the face in infinity
war which is to say it makes no sense
but i have to give it to bill burr for
this performance the guy has range
he's only getting more and more
opportunities so i guess i should remove
a sin for this
hang on i just said the scene makes no
sense add five more for
even making me think about taking one
away i never saw your face
miggs and therefore the show has time
for this you get the coordinates on love
gideon
we did what's our next move i don't know
but it's
definitely not going straight to the
coordinates and rescuing the kid because
that plan has a disturbing lack of side
quests involved
soon he will be back with me
letting your enemy know you're coming
for them cliche
is that gasoline i smell for some reason
you all want to wear the cinema synth
pitchfork m on your body so we slapped
that
on some new merch and threw it in the
store posters hoodies socks click on the
merch below
the youtube player or click the store
link at cinemasins.com
this isn't so bad huh
making bucks getting exercise
working outside
what did mix say to you multiple megs in
the next cell
he said i can smell your i see
i myself cannot you gonna tell me where
you're taking me
there's some lovely filth down here i'm
not gonna need long inside so once i get
the coordinates you guys got to get me
the hell out of there
you get to the roof i'll drop in and
pull
plan you out kid i
love it when a plan comes together i
wish i could say it look good on you but
i'd be lying
so you're telling me there's a chance
but you couldn't drive
of course i can drive why does everyone
say that
i used to drive i don't know how you
people wear those things
what do you mean you people
[Music]
get that
[Music]
what's your name officer my name is jeff
there's a special rug in hell reserved
for people who waste good scotch
seeing as i may be wrapping the door
momentarily i must say
damn good stuff sir
i regret nothing soon
he will be back with me i will look for
you
i will find you and i will kill you